after school I was like this I want to
create the next great after boyfriend
and that's that's what started it for me
I'm Tyler Haney I'm the founder and CEO
of outdoor voices and I'm 27 years old
outdoor voices comes from when you're a
little and your mom's like use your
inner voice it's got that spirit behind
it and we call it obeah for short after
high school I thought I'd go on to run
track and decided to take year off and
didn't wanted to figure out if that was
the right path for me ended up going to
Parsons for a business degree it was
called design and management and while
in school I was working out in these
other brands where their bright colors
and macho preparations and I started to
want to wear something some more simple
I really thought that there was some
beautiful balance between being feminine
and athletic that wasn't necessarily
bottled up in activewear brand and
that's really where I got the idea to
start outdoor voices in Parsons I became
fascinated with technical materials and
so found myself in mills that work with
Nike and Lulu Lemon and and really
started to dive into the science between
behind what makes something working or
compression oriented and that's where I
got my start
I think it's cool to be a seamless
Peschel going after brands that are
traditionally started by men but then
going into into offices with
male-dominated kind of venture
capitalists was even more encouraging
but it was hard started I've talked to
about 70 investors in the early days and
used it as fine-tuning for my brand deck
I'm very much sir I guess a risk-taker
so I don't have experience I'm on my
side but I have persistence